[Musique]
nous sommes dans un contexte de
réchauffement climatique lié à nos
activités et que les conséquences de ce
réchauffement climatique seront exin
extrêmement importante si nous ne
faisons rien pour en limiter amplitude
en gros si rien n'était fait nous irions
vers des regroupements 4 à 5 degrés à la
fin de ce siècle sévères pour les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui et des conséquences dans
beaucoup de domaines aussi bien sur le
séance mais aussi des événements
extrêmes qui deviendrait encore plus
extrême un peu par les cyclones on peut
parler de sécheresses d'inondations dans
notre région de canicule on pourrait
imaginer des températures dépenses a
ponctuellement 50 degrés en france et
voilà donc des conséquences aussi sur la
biodiversité sur la pollution sur les
problèmes de santé d'environnement
l'élévation du niveau de la mer donc des
conséquences très importantes et qui ne
peuvent pas laisser indifférent j'adhère
complètement aux objectifs de l'accord
de paris limitait réchauffement
climatique au moins deux degrés voire un
degré 5 par rapport à aujourd'hui on a
déjà pris un degré mais c'est un
véritable défi par exemple pour avoir
des chances de rester autour de 2 degrés
il faudrait que les engagements de
l'accord de paris sur la période 2020
2030 soit multiplié par trois pour un
degré 5 x 5 donc on est loin du compte
la corde par est un succès mais
largement insuffisant et d'autant plus
qu'il n'est pas respecté dans tous les
pays et que certains pays comme les
etats unis sont en train de le quitter
donc on voit bien la nécessité de
remonter l'ambition de l'accord de paris
mais on en voit bien la difficulté
également et c'est tout le défi de la
prochaine décennie si on veut lutter
efficacement contre le réchauffement
climatique est resté sur des
trajectoires qui permettrait aux jeunes
d'aujourd'hui de s'adapter réchauffement
climatique sera possible que si celui ci
est limité à 2 degrés effectivement même
un degré me par rapport à aujourd'hui
c'est un constat très clair il faut
aussi des investissements sans les
investissements et bien dit lançant des
investissements supplémentaires nous ne
réussirons pas au niveau de l'europe au
niveau de la france cette transition par
exemple au niveau de la france on estime
à 40 milliards 45 milliards
supplémentaires l'argent qu'il faudrait
injecter dans le système
disons dans notre économie pour réussir
la transition énergétique donc ils ont
la proposition c'est effectivement la
création d'une banque européenne pour le
climat allait de l'université avec des
prêts préférentiels mais aussi d'un
budget européen dédié de l'ordre de 100
milliards d'euros chaque année dont une
partie dédiée d'ailleurs à l'aide pour
l'afrique une partie dédiée à la
recherche
voilà et c'est ce pacte climat finances
climat que nous mettons en avant avec
aussi nous croyons l'homme l'idée de fin
d'année cit et d'entériner ces deux
outils ces deux approches par un
référendum qui permettrait de tout au
mois de mai révisé cette ce pacte donc
l'idée l'idée force du pack finances
climat ça vient du constat que les
investissements sont actuellement
insuffisant que ces investissements
doivent être faits au niveau de l'europe
et bien sûr aussi qu'ils seront
créateurs d'emplois et finalement de
bien-être pour les populations
européennes